What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity.
We know that you guys have been waiting for this a long time - and now it's happening.
One game match between me and Otto.
Let's go!
Don't give me there.
That's the biggest mistake you can make!
Almost!
Wow!
I didn't expect that one to come in.
That was the second mistake you made.
One was the around the net-
That was the second.
You need to move!
Don't be like me!
Sorry!
That was down!
I saw you switching hand
So I was like "let's give him one".
Thanks!
I didn't really saw that last shot coming in from there but that was nice!
Nothing special for me.
Let us know in the comments below what you want to see for the 800k special.
Remember to subscribe
And watch our previous episodes there.
Until next time!